hello everyone and welcome back to
another
play for all stream in aid of ablegamers
my name is tomorrow saying and it is my
pleasure to be joined by our very own
jordan remay
hello jordan hello and is even my even
greater pleasure to be joined
by the one and only song wong cho
how are you doing mate doing good man
thanks for having me
people people who are smart enough to
look next to someone's name will see
the the twitter handle pro zd and that's
probably what you know him as
on the internet and if you're wondering
why do i know pros led it is because
i mean is it fair to say that you're
like the thing that
catapulted you into success was your
frozen goofy song uh a bunch of stuff i
think you know there's vine there's
youtube
all sorts of stuff yeah uh i also am a
voice actor as well
um so you might know me from from that
but yeah
yeah i think i think the first thing
that i saw you in was that uh goofy
thing
and then the vines were where i was like
yeah i like this guy this guy's great
and then it's specifically it's the one
the one that i really loved and it's
such a simple one
is the one where uh the rpg one where
everyone dies and
you just get loads of money and the exp
thrown at you
that was such a good one but of course
you are also
known for your voice acting work you've
been in a whole bunch of stuff and
most recently you have been working on a
little game called boyfriend dungeon
which we have
on screen and we're going to look at a
bit of uh gameplay footage
from it um for a character that you
specifically play but before we get to
that how did you get involved in
in this game and also what's it been
like to jump from
you know traditional working on tumblr
doing stuff on tumblr and vine and
just putting stuff out there to being in
games now
um for this i think they just they just
asked me
uh i think to audition you know over
email um and so i just
sent them um my my my audition my take
on the character
um and they were happy with it uh as far
as the sort of how it's been
going from let's say you know online
stuff to voiceover i mean i've been
doing voiceover now
for you know eight nine years
so uh for me you know
it's it's i mean it's surreal right for
definitely like you know when i was
first starting out you know
uh aspiring one day to be in anything
and then now getting to do you know
animation and
video games and all that you know it
it's definitely surreal it was
something i uh really wanted and it
worked very very hard towards but it's
it's nice that finally it you know
managed to pay off
yeah i think that's the one of the most
impressive i mean you've got a great
voice but one of the most impressive
things is like
the work ethic which is something that
probably doesn't get a lot of attention
especially when it comes to voice actors
but like
seeing the amount of different platforms
that you've
appeared on and then become a big deal
on
is is like so impressive because like
tumblr is where a lot of it uh
people might have seen you and like
you're massive on tumblr and then vine
and then youtube and pretty much
everywhere else so it's just and that
doesn't come
just through talent it also comes
through a lot of hard work so
um that's that's pretty amazing and um
we're gonna look we're gonna look at um
some of the footage and have you like
discuss what's going on but before we do
that i just wanna highlight that of
course we are
raising money for ablegamers ablegamer
is an incredible charity
that uh combats social isolation and
works to create hardware and educate
people so that
gamers with disabilities are able to
access games a bit more so we are
raising money
for them um we are we're already at over
7k
um and uh you can go and donate at
tinyurl.com forward slash play for all
2021
um you might think a single dollar
doesn't do much but trust us if everyone
donates a dollar it's a big big
amount so please do uh open your your
hearts and your wallets
generously if you can um so your
character
in uh in boyfriend dungeon firstly
what is boyfriend dungeon for people who
aren't like me and jordan
and have been haven't been following
this very closely because of how weird
it is but what is it
or weebs i mean have you ever wanted to
romance a sword uh boy have i
yeah you know it's basically you're
you're going around you're dungeon
crawling but it's also like a dating sim
uh and um my character is
one of those uh uh hot hot swords that
you can
uh uh date in the game
so this is your character sunder right
yes
so how much of this character did you
see um
before you kind of signed up to do it or
were they like we just want your voice
we'll make a character for you
um they sh i believe they showed me the
art beforehand yeah i had the art and
then they had an idea what they wanted
the voice to sound like uh
and so i just kind of went with what
they were sort of
asking for right and it is it is like
wild because
you are there's so many swords in this
game and every sword has its own persona
which is typical for this day and age
where everyone's either hot for hades
characters
or into like rpg characters why do you
think this
this kind of weird how have we got to a
place where people are into like
inanimate objects
as and personifying them to as like
first traps
you know i don't think it's that odd i
think you know what in anime there's
they've
they've been like ships like boats like
there's that's the boat one there's like
the
uh i think you've had those sword one or
something in the past like this is
basically soul eater kind of
in a way oh yeah i guess just give
anything just give any things
personalities and make them hot
and uh you know there you go that's all
you really need
right yeah there's that one episode well
there's that one arc spoilers for one
piece where
where the like straw hat pirates have to
say goodbye to like the going merry
and and like that whole part of it i was
like wow these characters
are really into this ship and like that
is
it's that same kind of energy that i
expect that this this game is trying to
evoke like it wants you to get super
attached to these swords and
i mean your character has got an amazing
vibe going on in here
yeah i know he's fun yeah yeah i'm
looking forward to having people sort of
get to know him better uh as they play
the game that's the kind of thing i
wanted to ask about as well what's the
what is the arc like
with it with this kind of like character
or any character in this game is it
simply a case of like
they pop up and you kind of just talk to
them and that's it or is it a case of
like
you know you have to spend time and
effort into
investing in these characters and
bringing more of them out and
is it just are they are they like
because your character sunday here he's
like
very quickly he's like let's go on a
let's hang out or go on a date is there
a little more hot and cold that comes
from him
is or is he like easy to you know get
into bed
as far as the mechanics go i'm not
exactly sure how cuz you know i just
record all the dialogue
right um but without spoiling anything
uh i'll say there's more to the
character and the relationship i think
than it
initially appears you know like uh it's
not as simple as just
you know face value uh all right i
there's there's definitely like you know
there's a progression there's definitely
an arc
as well uh so i i
you don't want to say too much but again
yeah i'm
looking forward to having people sort of
uh discover that
that arc for themselves for sure but
boyfriend dungeon
is currently in development out um i
hope soon
you can find it on steam already and it
does have this whole dungeon crawling
element which looks really cool
however my question to you both of you
actually is
any gaming or anime sword that you could
date
which one would you pick because
i don't know any sword any anime or game
is because
you know in my mind i was like i wonder
i wonder what sephiroth sword probably
would look like i would i would try and
i will try and woo
sephiroth sword but who would you pick
if you had the option
i now understand why you asked me to sub
in for lucy because he probably doesn't
have enough
of a wee background to answer something
like this
damn there's been so many cool swords
i'll go for uh all three of zoro's
swords at once
oh wow oh that is
bold let's fight let's spice it up that
is both
boys that's a great pick though because
technically you get like i imagine
they're all different in their own ways
right so you get a nice mixture of
personalities
and uh physical flavors yeah you get a
lot of flavors
it's a lot of work though dating three
of them at once that's a lot of work
jordan
i would say i'm gonna cheat a little bit
so it's not
anime per se but the castlevania show
on netflix the four-prong sword that
trevor wields and the
final season i would love to see what
the
personality of that like erupts into
because it's one of these things where
it's
really small and it doesn't look all
that dangerous and but in like the hands
of someone who knows what they're doing
it's like this terrifying thing i'm like
how does that
translate personality wise
that's a good one that's a good one so
what we're gonna do for the rest of this
stream is
i have been i tweeted about this months
ago but i've been spending the last
couple weeks
really learning about myself but doing
it
by way of taking anime quizzes on the
internet
so i thought it would be fun i thought
it would be fun if we
if we gathered a few anime fans and uh
you know just
took some quizzes together and talked
about anime and
and see how we get on so someone i'm
gonna i'm gonna let you pick first
um what okay you your your subject
matter includes anime
villains attack on titan
kakashi specifically naruto as a whole
we've got my hero academia we've got
pokemon what do you do what do you want
to do a quiz about
let's start with villains okay so
this this one comes courtesy of
crunchyroll so you should be able to see
it in your discord window
but the quiz is can you name all of
these villains i
i am terrible at remembering names of
characters
so let's see let's see if you're better
than me i did this earlier and i was
like i definitely have seen this anime
but i cannot name that villain
are these multiple choice or do you have
to write them names uh i think they're
multiple choice
so that one's got it
this one well this is well this is uh
this is all for one
uh from my hero okay with his funky head
what is going on with that head is it
supposed to be just like a darth vader
thing do you do you reckon
i'm i'm freaking i'm not sure i forget
he like got
just can i swear on this by the way you
can sweat you can swear don't worry
about it
okay he got like [ __ ] up just doing
putting
he like he's getting quirks and [ __ ]
it's been a long time yeah all the all
the people on the channel
that's not what it is i mean i don't
care
but yeah his name is all for one okay
that is correct when this when this
villain went down it caused a ripple
effect for both heroes and villains
thank you for that trivia okay well this
is
obviously goku black i have not seen
i have not seen super but this is goku
black i
i think like the only way they could
make dragon ball more ridiculous or the
idea that goku has 11 million
transformations is to create another
goku that exists
and they sure as hell did it this is
he's like from the future or something
i think like it's like an evil goku from
a different timeline or
something like that jordan do you know
what the deal is with goku black
uh i feel like i'm gonna be talking out
of my ass but if
i remember correctly
it's isn't it like a goku from an
alternate
future that's right that seems right
like both of you have said that now so
so it must be right someone in chat is
probably like no it's not
um but at least we know he's just goku
and his godfather yeah he's just
he dyed his hair what is there of the
death busters looks to make earth into a
new
home okay uh
so this is sailor moon right but
who is this uh i've actually only read
the manga
so i don't remember it that well i know
who queen beryl is she's like the iconic
link
yeah death busters death busters
um i'm gonna go with uh i don't think
this is a clean barrel
it doesn't look like it i'll say i'm
gonna say death phantom let's write
death phantom i like it
jordan do you know or do you have any
input into this that might help us
no because sailor moon is one of my
blind spots
that is absolutely disgusting behavior
you should be watching
i'm sorry there's only so many hours in
the day
you should devote some to sailor moon um
don't be too on the nose though i feel
like it's a trick death buster is dead
yeah
let's go for it i feel like death
phantom makes sense but you know it's
going to be like masterfair or nighty
which it sounds like
that sounds like a yu-gi-oh card yeah it
sounds like a yu-gi-oh either a yu-gi-oh
card or like the
the one of the lost members of the
wu-tang clan
um right it was not
it was mastered it was the yugioh
90. i see from say them in crystal
especially so i don't
definitely don't know yeah okay okay
oh what the [ __ ] is this is like what oh
right yeah this is this looks like a
borrowed
character i've i often after naruto
finished i was like i'm out
i'm done i don't know how long this is
going to carry on for so i'm done
okay um
does that say delta that says delta so
what is that koji kashi koji
well i'm not gonna i'm gonna cross out g
again because i don't want him to have a
like the same name as a cool lupine
character yeah so no no
uh urashiki doesn't maybe
koji kashi i don't think i don't think
this guy has like two names i think this
guy's just like
one name delta you know it's probably
something
stupid like delta but i'm gonna go
let's go urashiki jordan any insight
jordan why do you even watch anime
what's wrong with you dude
i've been led to believe that you're
like why
continue watching all right we've got a
good point
yeah we're going for urashiki that's
correct
yes ability to manipulate temperature
the next generation
i i i always thought about jumping into
boruto and then i didn't just because of
how stupid the name is boruto
it's like naruto and they were like
boruto i was like no i'm not down with
this
you're better you're probably better off
not trying to negotiate anything with
this villain
villain i don't recognize this
she looks familiar but i cannot i
haven't seen this it's
well i'm gonna guess it's not julius uh
uh can you can you read the names for me
here so we've got a little hard to read
okay uh oh there we go yeah that's
better that's much better okay so much
better yeah
so tella sounds like nutella elsa
grand here peter juice romani country
you know
you know it's that one uh
okay elsa graham the arch that sounds
like
like a grand blue fantasy character yeah
so tell that sounds like nutella
petal juice okay i'm gonna my gut
i'm gonna say satella you just think
you're right
creamy chocolatey satella i think that's
it
okay we're gonna go for nutella i have
no idea what i have no idea
zero no this isn't right here what's
that you get some characters that have
this smile
like what is with this smile it's like
the you can see the
lower lip or it's like got lipstick on
it but they never had the upper lip and
it i don't know what they didn't have
time
i didn't have time sometimes they don't
have time you know but what is that
expression trying to convey
um that she's got a store a bottom lip
yeah it's like kind of like i'm i'm kind
of sensitive but i'm kind of goofy
um yeah right nutella oh it's not no it
was else
[Music]
wow ladies do not let this man have your
hand
no matter what so this guy i do know i
haven't
watched this far but he's from part four
this is yoshiga
yoshikage kira yeah she kind of heard a
lot about him
yeah heard a lot about him but i have
not uh seen this yet
very long eyebrows on this lad i respect
it i respect it a lot
um nailed it diamond is underneath
unbreakable yeah i need to i need to
watch more jojo jojo feels like i've
never been intimidated by anime getting
into anime at all but jojo is the one
where i'm like
very intimidated by really you're not up
on one piece
uh i bet i bailed on one piece i
made i made a decision i made a decision
and i was like
this is never gonna end i need to go i
gotta go
[Laughter]
you're lost man you're lost but all
right i i i am gonna dip back in i think
soon
so like i there was a period where i was
working um and not in the video game
industry and i was working
in for like the train service and i used
to stand on a platform and just read the
manga on my phone when
in between trains come in so i i think i
over
consumed one piece for a while and i
needed a break
um but i am due for coming back in
uh all right next one ah
well speaking of speaking of you know
speaking so i know this answer
uh don't click it but who do you what do
you think this character's name is uh
kaido that's correct this is yeah so i'm
still aware of one piece i've got
i check in i check in check it's like on
the peripheral of your knowledge
well i i my younger brother if you go
into my younger brother's room
i mean like the man's he's a grown man
like me but he's got every one of the
straw hat pirates one uh wanted posted
up on his wall
just like framed it up so like i i have
an obligation to maintain
uh knowledge around it i don't know what
his deal is
i ain't got a clue but um he's the
strongest creature in the world
sick i mean yeah i was actually watching
the
uh fight where uh luffy activates gear
second for the first time the other day
at the gym
and um i was like i was on i was on a
stationary bike and doing it and someone
like
clearly walked past and looked at me and
was like
you're too old for this man and i was
like no you're never too old
no you you're never too old now had you
gotten that far
when you read it uh yeah yeah so i got
up to
i got beyond nes lobby um
so i think i got to marineford
is that america where they're where the
celestials are about and luffy the last
episode i remember watching
and reading up to was there's a
celestial and luffy punches it
and everyone freaks out which is a real
real long time ago
um okay cool
oh he's known as the red comet but if
you look away he might have an
entirely new name oh okay
um this again feels like something that
i should know the answer this is
familiar this is a gundam thing very
iconic
oh man what's his name it's not rhonda
rawl i don't think i don't think it's
amaro ray it's either char
assistant or garma zombie i think oh
god oh god
i think this is char i have never seen
this
so i i like but that name is some more
familiar
i'm gonna go with char drop it in char
cha jordan thank you i think yeah
i think yeah okay we've locked in my if
my gundam friend
has steered me correctly okay we're
gonna lock in char but what is the chat
saying jordan can you see
chad well i don't want to know it might
be a little i'll say right now
the chat is oh yeah the chat saying char
the chat is also saying that tam you
need to watch
jojo well if you donate to tinyurl.com
and we can get up to maybe let's say
seven if we get to 8 000 i will start a
youtube channel where i
watch jojo and give you weekly reports
how about that you won't
don't lie to the chat listen i never lie
i'm a man of my word and we'll do it
we're locking in char
okay all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna check in after each question
to see if the chat got it right as well
okay okay jordan don't cheat no
idea what the [ __ ] this this this looks
i don't know is this black clover it
kind of gets black
yeah it looks like black clover but like
the mouth is got big bleach energy as
well but i know it's not bleached that's
no one i've seen in police
this guy's name could be maurice oh
hello he's maurice
uh okay i don't think it's mars ladros
that's a little
uh lotus humalt
it's that what you ask when you see like
uh a malt
on like a diner
i don't think it's mars it's probably
something stupid like ladros
ladros uh yeah that's boris
[Laughter]
this guy looks like a lad i'll say
ladders
okay that seems like a safe answer okay
you got it yeah from black clover you
got the anime as well you nailed it
that's impressive nailing the anime
based on art style is not easy
there we go they're surprising
unfortunately okay but let's
go down team epic so uh
it's not peeping me or poopoko because
that's those two
right so i wanna go up
the surprising true villain i mean i i
feel like
this show would do something really meta
and make it just like king records
uh yeah like take shobo
sounds like and the fact that there's
five of them
i'm going to say king records i feel
like they would do yeah
more than one here king records yeah
after a great crazy joke
yep you know
everyone's oh [ __ ] so this is mob psycho
and i remember i remember this character
don't remember his name
it's not sarizawa i don't think because
i think that's the
other guy with the umbrella maybe
shimazaki oh my god jordan you love mob
psycho so i
you hey i think
it's toichiro suzuki i think
i don't seriously was a different guy
shimazaki i think is also a different
guy
i don't hiroshi shibata is not even
ringing a bell
so my guess is toichiro suzuki
no saki's definitely not
okay well i think it's the bottom one i
like him
i think he's right i think someone is
right okay
yeah yeah he nailed it okay you're
smashing this you're killing this
oh this is dr stone but i don't know who
this is okay so let's see
um this guy looks like he'd have like a
single name like prince
yeah so yeah i'm gonna go hyoga
he look he looks like he's evil enough
or he's just like yo
i'm hyoga i don't go i don't do yeah or
whatever are we going for yoga
but oh if you've read it
but listen this isn't your quiz this is
my mistakes tonight
yeah i was going to say it you have
final say it'll it'll be a point for you
if it's tsukasa but for me
i'm i said yoga already so that was my
mistake so
we have to lock in hyoga that's a lock
in hyogo but you were right yeah you're
all right
congratulations so you get a bonus point
oh this is a good one
a dastardly heel that pushes two
wrestlers in completely different
directions this is king or arma king is
it is this like
is this like what is it like bucky the
grappler or something i have no idea i i
don't recognize this at all
it kind of looks like that bucky the
grappler but
is bucky the grappler toy i
i don't think so was this is this that
isakai where the wrestler goes to
another world
and he uh and it's like a world of
beast creatures and so he's able to
survive because he's like a wwe wrestler
or something
am i talking out of my ass i think it's
that god
i don't know if that's a real thing my
guest just stopped because these two
dancers are too similar big tiger the
second and tiger the great the third
i think it's one of those two i'm gonna
go with the one that sounds dumber
tiger the great to the third so
i think that's tiger the
i don't even know what that is i don't
know what that is i'm gonna get you
anonymous for the 20
donation we appreciate it thank you
anonymous thank you
what is tiger mask w i have no idea
we're gonna find out
it oh i guess
i've never seen this this sounds
wild okay note to self watch that
ah i know this very well do either of
you know the answer
uh everyone goes through numerous trials
and tribulations
so this villain's antics
i don't recognize this i don't but
based on looking at it i would say this
this
this character has dahlia hawthorne
energy
that is correct this is from phoenix
wright this is the ace attorney
oh i thought so i haven't seen the anime
but i know the game so yeah okay say
mata spinelli is listening to this and
shaking his head at us
okay for most of the series he's not the
kind of brother you'd want
i don't know what this is from no i
thought that was uh
from my hero himiko toga
yeah i feel like this
guy wow what is this from i don't know
that nemo one of the answers is nemo
yeah i would have said black clover
again
so if it's not black clover and it's not
re-zero
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is my
guess though
i don't think it's a full name this
looks like some fantasy [ __ ] looks i
think
i'm gonna say finis finish this is
finished yeah
okay i'm gonna say nemo but
this is yours so okay yeah you were
right you were right
what is called realized guardians
realized guardian of
rebirth what the hell is that i have
missed that
let's let's find out friends let's find
out together
this has got adam this is a ps vita game
what the hell
it's an atomic visual novel for the
playstation v a rest in peace
via wow
uh you've got to watch out for programs
turn into villains
don't know what this is either we call a
utorrent fourth one
the fourth option like isn't it it's
just it's just utorrent
the fourth one is uh isn't that maybe
maybe this is my love live brain talking
but isn't that muse
isn't that the symbol for muse maybe not
the only thing that it just looks like
the utorrent logo for me which
ironically is where i watch most of my
got most of my anime so
um you might be right bp does not seem
right
thorn seems like a different show yeah
shonen doll hold on go up go up to the
description
you've got to watch out for programs
that turn into villains you might be
right with this
i didn't know yet shonen doll is such an
interesting name it seems like it'd be
hard to make that
up yeah my i'll say shonen doll
i'll say sean i don't know what this is
yeah
it wasn't it was utorrent from caligula
oh from caligula
i don't know what that is okay what is
that i
let's find out to get no i'm not gonna
google caligula that's just gonna
waste our time bullies can also be
villains especially this one from orange
the chat the chat got that right wow
okay if i'm looking at this
nondescript character here oh my god i
love orange why can i not remember this
person
oh yeah and you don't have an excuse
[ __ ]
jordan you're revealing yourself to be
not a very good weave today god
my guess i think if this is a bully
for some reason naho takamiya that to me
has like a bully sounding name
see i was we're gonna go i want to
remember it's the character
who is like preventing the main heroine
from
being with her love interest by
uh pretending to date see a kid
i was a bad girlfriend we're gonna go
with naho because that's what someone
chose but using the same logic i went to
azusa
as the villain name interesting let's
see though
it wasn't correct
yeah ah interesting
he's erratic unpredictable and that
metal plate isn't just a fashion oh
golden caramel he's good too
why didn't oh okay this is golden
commonly
i'm pretty sure oh man i'm gonna be
i think it's tokushiro surumi yeah this
is
like i'm like 90 sure you're right this
character is pretty great and i'm
appreciative
okay i'm about to lock it in yeah are
you all right
from golden can we i've not seen golden
villains who play shogi can be very good
at being manipulative
is this like what is this is this juicy
kaisen or something
no i've not seen this character in
judaism unless i'm missing out
it's like this a shogi anime is this is
this march comes in like a lion
maybe it would be that's yogi right okay
well anyway yeah
but the art style looks kind of
different
i'm gonna say this guy strikes me as a
masumune goat pill
that's a badass name masa goto is such a
villainous name
okay we're going to go with that and you
are right
man what do i know
he's the absolute worst teacher
imaginable
no idea what this is uh okay there's
been a lot of bad teachers in anime
gaku yashiro toriya kenya kobayashi
these names are familiar what is this
this is
i'm gonna guess satoru fujinuma
that's give me my guess some of these
nope no
oh [ __ ] it's wrong
well i shouldn't say anything but it's
the the guy
from a race wait no
this is like that's like the
protagonist's name i think
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my god
this is embarrassing although it's been
a while since i've seen a race
oh dude you got 14 out of 20.
correct for every one you get correct in
these quizzes i'm gonna donate a dollar
so i i gotta donate fourteen dollars
once this is done
okay for everyone that i get wrong i'm
gonna donate at least
at least a dollar so okay at least six
dollars so far
okay uh awesome yeah okay you got 14 out
of 20 there that's good
uh let's get rid of the anime villain
quiz next quiz
this is a quiz relay can you see these
yeah
not really okay so you can do really
tiny yeah do you want it do you want to
figure out
whether what what demon slayer character
you are
would you be a hero a villain in my hero
academia which pokemon you are which
metal gear character you are
um uh is there one that's just trivial
done with these personality ones but i
want to do ones that are like
excuses like this like getting questions
right okay okay okay
uh we've got
what is the ultimate anime quiz the
ultimate anime quiz let's try that one
is that it right there what is that that
is it
the ultimate anime quiz ready
yeah let's do it yeah hopefully this
doesn't take us to a weird website tokyo
ghoul what's the name of
this is really small let me see what's
the name of a ghoul
whose organs were transplanted to the
main hero okay
go down isn't this kid
named ken kaneki so my guess is
the ghoul is yoshimura that's just i
want to say that
if for another reason it's the only
singular word and i feel like it would
be a term
not a name
yep do we find out now or we'll find out
let's see what we'll say oh it didn't
tell us so we finally find out at the
end
find out at the end okay goku is
uh just make sure yep okay just saying
okay which of these death notes rules is
incorrect so hey the conditions of death
will not be realized unless they are
physically possible for that human or
could reasonably or be reasonably
assumed to be carried out by that human
the death knot will not ever affect a
victim whose name has been misspelled
four times
you cannot kill humans with less than
five minutes of life left in human
calculations
and finally once the victim's name cause
of death and conditions of death have
been written down in the death note the
death will take place even if that death
note
or part of the note used is destroyed
before the stated time of death
this is either gonna be i forget if they
destroyed death notes in that show
i don't remember if they try or that's
even a thing i think they
try and get rid of them at a time at one
point and they keep reappearing
is correct yeah i think it's gonna be
one of those things where it's like it's
actually
three times instead of four yeah i think
it's something stupid like that
so my guess is
i think c is right i think d
i don't remember anything about
destroying death notes my guess is that
this is some stupid trick question not
trick but like
b is the answer because it's actually
misspelled four times or three times
four seems like a weird number for that
to be that way
usually it's like a three time three
strikes you're out right right right
right
so i'll go with b my other i guess is d
but i think this one yeah i think b is b
as well but we'll lock that in for now
we'll walk in b
yeah let's see how that goes
[Laughter]
who's the lieutenant of the 11th
division in season one
we've got yeah
guys
okay little pink hair oh it is her isn't
it
yeah i was not a fan of her i found her
to be too annoying i'm sad i know this
but yeah
yeah i mean i was a i was a kampachi fan
so
hurricane you got to know that it's the
lieutenant yeah
but i just which of these people is not
part of levi's squad
uh all these are like petrol
um all attack on titan name is just like
oh
hans hans gruber
so yeah they all kind of blend together
yeah this this
this one mobile burner is is the most
fake name i've seen
in ever so i i only seen the first
season attack on titan armin was like
uh what's his face's friend right uh the
main guy
yeah yeah aaron's friend so it's either
like oh it's army because he's not
the other names i don't know yeah
are you not a fan of attacking titan i i
mean it's fine i just have i've only
seen the first season
so i don't know much about it i watched
the first season i thought it was
bang average and i have a i i
pretty good i really dislike uh um aaron
as a character
because every time he like proclaimed he
was gonna like murder the titans like
the next scene would be him getting
stepped on by a titan
and it happened like eight times in
season one i was like this guy's
pathetic
and mikasa should be the main character
she's clearly the most competent person
i do agree with you there obviously the
answer is a no it's uh
come on now come on ultimate anime quiz
my ass
did you know that this character was
named mewtwo because there's already a
mu
and he's actually the second one which
makes it mean that is
i don't believe you i think that's it
i'm telling you that's that's the law
trust me some deep pokemon
uh sailor moon jordan you're up uh
who's guardian can't answer these
questions who's guardian cat and advisor
is luna
really you don't know who luna it's uh
do you not know the sailor scouts names
i mean i
i do not watch sailor moon
like if you told me it's like which ones
uh
moon which one sailor mars which one
sailor jupiter like i could like pick
them out
in a lineup but that's like the extent
of my knowledge which one okay well the
answer
is sailor moon which of these names do
you think is sailor moon's
name if you had to guess
come on you can do it i believe in you
jordan e b
maybe nope nope
jordan i'll need your weave badge and
gun by the end of the day
you got a gun yeah
ah code gears cc is slightly
obsessed with pizza yes pizza
yeah controversial controversial
i wasn't a fan of code gears either yeah
called yes sucks you're right
wow are you serious wow
oh my god finally someone that agrees
with me
every time i've said this i feel like
i've been attacked for it
nah nah it sucks it's boring as hell
man and it ends on the worst cliffhanger
i've ever seen
in anything thank you oh my god
who's the strongest meister to graduate
from death weapon
meister academy this is solely uh
the strongest the strongest meister
krona frankenstein oxford and death the
kid
i mean death the kid is one of the kids
i think yeah
freaking signs of their teacher kronos
like a
bad guy i think i think i'm gonna guess
oxford
okay i would say so yeah all right let's
see how we going
a long time since i've seen soul eater
and so late or not
remember folks you can donate using the
url tinyurl.com four slash playful 2021
i'm i'm enjoying myself i'm sure you're
enjoying yourself
why not kick us a few bucks so we can
pass that on to
some a charity that's going to help out
gamers and
you know make life easier for them and
combat social isolation
please do it what is the name of the
great
toad oh okay it's not gamma bunta
no that's his that's that's his that's
one
right he's a little one yeah i'm gonna
it's either gamamaro or just
gamma uh come on maru sounds like
almost um it's like
if you became a frog yeah just write up
gama
like comma i guess drama means frog
i'm assuming because it's names i'll say
gamma sure
yeah okay sure
not listen it's win-win when when when i
get a point
lose more money for charity yeah exactly
all right spread it away what's the name
of the elderly man who helps chihiro
find a work at the bath house
and spirit it away
oh my god what is his name are they
talking about the guy with the spider
arms
i think so that's what i assume the
elderly man
i think it's kamaji right i mean
i don't even remember them like saying a
name like it's been
so long since i've seen spirit of kamaji
yeah
okay we're looking common g uh denver a
asks in the chat are you guys reading
youtube comments i am
but uh the others shouldn't be otherwise
they'll be seeing answers
um aside from spirited away and house
movement castle what is the third
highest grossing anime movie worldwide
this is taking a sudden turn into box
office numbers
interesting wouldn't this like change
depending on what year this quiz is
yeah like there have been some really
popular anime films in the past
because community trained has beaten
spirited away now at this point
so it i'm okay go up it's spirited away
in
howls yeah your name get that high
it might have your name was number
one in japan at some point i mean it was
pretty
successful here yeah it was
internationally successful
what might be your name i'm gonna say
your name i'm gonna say your name
finally someone's saying my name
okay cowboy bebop which character has an
artificial eye
oh come now do you guys not know this
uh who has an artificial eye it's got to
be jet right
i think it's jet no no no is it not like
it's not is it spike does this spike
that has it
he does episode is that but they reveal
he has an artificial eye
there's this whole thing where it's like
he's like oh i'm looking through
like time through one eye oh yeah
god damn i guess that that means i'm do
a i think you both need to turn in your
weeb card
yeah yeah i'm doing well we got another
uh donation from uh
matt hawking 10 sorry i missed the
earlier stream had a work meeting
shout out to my fellow minnesotan pro zd
hey thank you hey thank you thank you so
much matt
okay fairy tale who's the dragon slayer
pupil of
dragon skydram ain't seen photo
i don't know what good anime yeah i
don't know what any of this means
this uh
uh who is the dragon slayer player
people of the dragon skeleton now
i'm gonna try to guess okay
these are all stupid okay so sting is
the light dragon slayer
rogue is darkness godzilla is iron
and irene
the [ __ ] is irene this sounds bad i've
never seen fairy tale but it sounds bad
it sounds bad it gets it's like a really
good anime for like the first 48
episodes and it's like a
300 episode anime so it's like it's just
yeah okay
okay uh go up again what's the name
skladrum
dragon slayer people yeah
drum i'm gonna guess maybe that's the
light dragon
c gagil red fox or rdd the irene
okay i can't even remember which dragon
slayer irene is
like she must have been introduced after
i stopped watching
in my neighbor totoro what are the small
dark dust-like house spirits called
kappa daspani susuwatari or tanuki
oh i don't know the japanese name so i
guess it's
susuwatari because we call them soot
sprites
over here yeah
i mean kappa is not it's not copper
or not a yeah we don't call
what is the name of iniasha's older
brother oh easy
you guys know this uh i've never seen
one of the ones i just never got around
to i definitely downloaded it and had it
on
vcd but
[Laughter]
uh what's the name of the community worn
by ryoko matui
junketson uh
i thought it sent you
another anime that i i pieced out of
because of
the weird boob jiggly thing that they do
every year actually i haven't seen much
i was like i can't i can't like i
this is too embarrassing pretty good i i
heard it's amazing for that one
animation
hunter x hunter what is hisoka's nan
ability called
uh i know this one it is bungee gum
bungee gum sucker is my favorite
character in hunter hunter
it's pretty great he's a weirdo
what is tsuyu asuy's ability
oh frog i'm now kai
[Music]
who is going to have another donation
from nawaz for
five dollars thank you noah thank you uh
someone who's your favorite my hero
character
oh uh eraserhead that is a
girl great picture that was a great pick
my mine is mine goes between tokoyami
um because tokyo is great he's basically
like kid batman
but uh crow but i also like snipe sensei
oh okay knife sensei is sick
there's that other one as well that like
i think he's called ectoplasm
everyone cementos rules cementos is
amazing as well
that is a great one cementos is the best
name for sure
um which of the following is among the
angels
pretty sure it's romeo romeo
yeah it's been a long time
my memory just sucks um which two
homunculi possess
true forms gluttony and sloth envy and
pride lust and
greed um is it
the uh envy and pride yeah
who's your favorite uh fullmetal
alchemist character
might be hawkeye oh that's a great pick
that's a really good pick
damn you like mine's mustang 100 mine's
mustang
mustang is great he's so good do you
want
to pick between those two characters you
know the answer it's
shaw tucker everyone loves shaw tucker
oh he's a good
wholesome nice man i hate you so much
every year on father's day i post a
tweet about show tucker and it
absolutely in the internet is molding
whenever i do it they just
hate it so much i'm like relaxed man
uh what is saitama's intelligence rating
as determined by the hero association
so i know that legend's rating don't
think very highly of him
no i'm gonna guess four
four it's either four or six i don't
think it's one
i think it's six i thought it was six do
you think it's six yeah
jojo's bizarre adventure as i have said
i'm not i'm not seeing all of it yet
what's the name of jonathan joestar's
ripple mentor
i might actually know this um
yeah okay yeah so i've seen that far
i've seen just enough
ghost in the shell major makoto sanagi
is
the squad leader of what team
is it five oh this is terrible because
they
just differentiating it by the numbers
yeah
i think nine thinking okay you might be
right nine
i think so all right we're going with
nine unless standalone complexes
it's too late we've committed best of
the north star
continue the phrase oh my god
yeah oh my one more nani is a great
phrase though
about to say please let it be nani
you got 17 out of 25 okay let's see
what you got incorrect tokyo ghoul oh
death
not got us levi squad gotta say
no got us attack on titan
uh later i was sure we were gonna get
that
so the great toad was gamma mural
yeah fairy tale dragon slayer we got
that one wrong
i like that wrong evangelion wrong
oh [ __ ] it's not romeo [ __ ] okay
okay so his intelligence must have been
six then
this they didn't share the christmas
they told us what the actual right
answer was
this trivia quiz lagoon you suck
all right i got eight wrong so it's like
eight more dollars you got it
cool i've got 17 um how many was in the
last one
17 14 right was it 14
so i got 14 i'm keeping track i got 14
wrong so far okay
okay i'll match whatever you do that'll
make things easier
okay we've done this one
oh i opened my elden ring secret file
folder no one saw that don't worry about
it
uh okay
naruto trivia time for a tuning exam
thank you trivia let's go
i do not you already know enough about
naruto to know the answers to
any of this oh my god oh my god
what are the choices the choices are
january 1st
july 13th may 2nd october 10th
i don't know naruto's birthday okay
it's 1 1 7 13 five two ten ten you think
anything has something like
fun like 10 10 um
i say july 13th who cares july 13th july
13th
13th yeah yeah yeah it wasn't it was
october 10th
it was the fun one yeah yeah okay
how many times did naruto failed the
graduation exam
in ninja academy uh
i think it was three the graduation exam
wasn't it definitely wasn't 20. 20 is
way too much no
uh what's the graduation exam is that
just before tune in is that just
so tune in tuning so they he passed
these ganning exams
so graduation is off to tuning tuning
was the
is that the one in the forest
it would only be one time that he only
ever did it once
tuning skin was oh the graduation exam
at the well at the the academies i think
before the tuning
because it's like that's when our little
kids yeah that's the
that's the scene of the greatest fight
of all time the lee versus gara one
you love that scene oh god don't get me
started
one i think it's just one there's just
one i think you only feel it
let's see i'm gonna get the scroll and
get better and then like that's the
whole first chapter i thought it was
three
hours yeah three three times whatever uh
what is the name of kakashi's father
yeah i know this one oh no no
no no oh you you nearly screwed that one
up dude
that's right what am i doing
oh my god i was like
who is in team seven nato sakura
and sasuke
there's no a fourth uh no there is no
fourth oh
i don't remember the [ __ ] team
numbers i team
seven is that not the classic narcissist
i i thought i thought team seven naruto
say i'm pretty sure naruto's team is
team seven yeah that's what i thought
do it lock it in seven that's correct
yeah okay
love to see it what is the name for the
first level of ninja
gaining yes
how many tailed beasts are there
uh nine right nice see the problem we
have here is
does it count the final one that
combines them
because that would be ten no that would
be two nine
yeah it has to be nine
who has a crush on naruto me that's who
definitely
sakura all of us uh
of course yeah
what do you do you think that was a good
pairing someone hinata
the scene where they get married that
[ __ ] was emotional man i don't go back
to that
i did not get that i didn't get that
dude
she gives him a scarf don't get me
started it made me cry
okay name of keyboard
okay whose dog is pakun do you remember
that
that's uh that's kakashi's yeah
oh you're a naruto guy
[Applause]
okay uh which is
grandfather that's the second hokage
second
yeah it's not the third it's the second
second sure
it's hashirama it's the first one what
really
yeah oh wait well they're brothers right
the first and second are brothers
are they brothers no they're from two
different clans no they're from two
different clans they're buddies i think
i don't know anything uh who gave it to
obito yeah
okay one piece uh i'm sure we could find
one um
okay well this is rockley obviously who
is the only ninja who can use taijitsu
who's the best ninja that's what it
should be
how old was hitachi when sasuke was born
when he was born i'm gonna guess i don't
like five
five i thought it was seven but maybe
you're right let's go five
five it's five yeah you got it you got
it you don't listen to me don't listen
to this guy
um what is the name of tsunade's
boyfriend
what is that it's done
are you sure it's not chris yeah for
some reason
[Laughter]
imagine that it's my boyfriend chris
hey i'm chris ninjason yeah
it's not his biggest face sharp items
blood water that's such a [ __ ]
fear to have like you work as a ninja
primarily with sharp objects
and you punch so hard that stuff
explodes you better get used to blood
uh damn she had a traumatic experience
with the blood
uh naruto ichiraku ramen of course yeah
yes one percent picked doughnuts
what lunacy who wrote the books kakashi
is always reading
uh no idea
yeah pervert guide from snake man
what piece is the famous jewelry that
akatsuki war
they were oh nose rings right yeah
they don't wear wrong like they wear
rings wait they wear rings
so it has to be ring or nose ring
because glasses and scrunchies are not
jewelry which sami doesn't wear a nose
ring
kasami's a fish man he wouldn't be able
to he's
only got gills are you sure do they i
don't i don't think
all of them or do they all have a nose
ring
it's been so long i i don't remember
do they have all i can think was their
stupid cloaks
this is not stupid someone it's not
stupid
no it's not it has to just be ring
it has to be ring it can't be nose ring
it has to be ringing yeah it's got to be
a ring because kisame doesn't wear
nose ring rings but again again he
doesn't have a nose he's a fish man
it has to be ringed ham i do you're
trying to
dissuade us they do not wear nose rings
what does goddess tattoo mean
uh love isn't it pretty sure it's love
jordan
well the only thing i remember about
this character is that cali
loves him he's for sure he's a good boy
love it's love
how many dogs does kakashi have this is
a good one two
twelve eight or twenty while these wells
well
while they're thinking about it uh
please remember that you can go to
tinyurl.com for slash playful to donate
um we would love to get to 7500 by the
end of the stream so please do we've got
just
an hour left um so speaking of donations
i have a
few more to please
we have another 25 from anonymous with a
note for
nice one lads i think that's in regards
to the last quiz
thank you we have a ten dollar donation
from kappa
noodles and a note that says tam i'm
going to need a confirmation on you
watching all of the release jojo animes
as in part one two three four and five
also maybe a weekly watch of part six
when it starts
i will i will do that i will do that uh
you won't do that there's no way you do
that
and then we have a 20 donation from
imran
and he says that i am here to take tams
and jordan's weeb cards
oh wow someone how many dogs does hatake
kakashi have
i say 12 when we say 12. 12. it was in
fact eight
oh okay all right what did hitachi
always do to sasuke that sound that is a
smaller word yeah that i mean it's way
more than
clearly he always like murders his
friends and family that's what he does
all right there we go who is sakura's
best friend enemy this is a great
picture
by the way it's like bigger aggrets got
energy on this
uh you know obviously you know
uh ten-ten worst character no
whoa hold on there buddy sucks man
what is what is samihata that is a sword
that is a kisame sword it's a fishboy
sword isn't it
yeah yeah name
all the members in team 10. oh my god
okay
do you know what it's about yeah uh
i think it's choji shikamaru you know
right isn't it that group
yeah sure yeah canonically
canonically this should be uh
the other way right it should be oh yeah
you know
so they screwed this up crunchyroll
you're supposed to know anime get your
[ __ ] together
got a bunch of phonies fakers
what is the name of shizune's pet
is bacon
20 out of 24. not bad that's very good
that's pretty good very good um okay
we've done the naruto quiz
now and the other ones involve uh like
getting trivia right
these ones are these are these are the
ones let's drill down into a specific
character
how much do you know about hatake
kakashi
not enough to get everything right let's
go
let's go i need to make a friend of mine
take this quest
this is an easy one who was on kakashi's
team
as a child oh obviously rin and obito
come on okay yeah correct
who did kakashi beat to pass the tuning
exams
oh that's interesting uh i don't know
this i'm gonna guess mike guy
that's really why they have such a
intense rivalry jordan
i have no idea um we're gonna
hold side with the majority and go with
my guy that was correct
unacceptable um how did kakashi lose his
eye
rushing forward to attack a bad accident
struck by a large vote
while protecting friends while
protecting a friend right
i wish it was struck by a large bird
that was
incredible
what did minato what task did minato
give kakashi
investigate the nine tails demon watch
over his pregnant wife locate the
whereabouts of orochimaru infiltrate the
uchiha clan
[Music]
so you can at least you ask watch at
least eliminate one right
no no i know i know a couple that i i'm
pretty sure are not it but yeah
was rochimar doing this crazy [ __ ]
around this time i don't know orochimaru
was always doing crazy [ __ ] like from
the get-go when he was a kid he was like
i got snakes i'm about to do some crazy
[ __ ]
what task did binato give kakashi i'm
going to say you know what maybe
richmond was doing crazy [ __ ] we'll do
it yeah over there
okay we're gonna go with orochimaru
um why did third hokage take kakashi out
of the ambu
probably it would only darken his heart
or something like that the other options
are he had more talent elsewhere
it was not his fate and he'd seen it in
a dream so we're going with dark and his
art has to be directly in this heart
i'm pretty sure ambi was led by dunzo at
that point and he was pretty [ __ ] up
so
you were right uh
what in particular does kakashi want to
teach to team seven
work as a team how to forget their path
i love that
that is correct this one's a bit too
easy what is kakashi's contest
record against mike guy at the start of
this series i spoke too soon
[Laughter]
i think it's isn't it like oh god like
okay so who's
who's the winner yeah this is the
oh yeah this is the this is the part of
the series at the start of the series
who is in the lead and who is not that's
what you got to figure out
i think i think is it in a tie
isn't it 50 50 is that i could
i could have sworn one of them was
winning but maybe you're right maybe it
was a tie
well the way this is phrased implies
that kakashi is losing right what is
kakashi's record
50 losses and 40 so i'm going to say i'm
gonna guess 50 50. it's one of those two
i think it's okay 50 50. but i thought
it was 50 by 49 but
i think it's 50 49. yeah yeah
okay what technique did kakashi create
rasengan
isn't it
holy [ __ ] uh from caleb
loving the stream thanks everyone for
being here two hundred dollar donation
oh wow
thank you so much caleb that's amazing
thank you so much that's so cool what
book does kakashi read during the
initial balta
test make oh i think it's make out
paradise in the first one i know i think
tactics is another one
paradise paradise that's correct hr
tactics
is another one yeah what is the name of
the pogba
oh yeah we already know this one look at
his little face
look at his little face i love him when
he does a little bite another great
screenshot
yeah when kakashi became hokage
which number was he
oh
sixth is that what you're going with
yeah you're correct
in between right um
after fighting daedra the overuse of
what causes kakashi to collapse
is it a manga kill shotting gun or
something
probably i think it is that's correct
yeah
yeah damn naruto is good man it is
what is kakashi's last words to kakuzu
it didn't have to be this way it has it
never has to be this way
thank you for teaching me about the
future i hope you find your piece kakuzu
one after another a new generation he's
kind of a dick i don't think kakashi is
nice to him so i think it's the last
that's correct yeah
that is correct who does kakashi first
talk to after
pain spoilers killed him
pretty sure it's his father right uh so
your options are his father hirozan rin
and obito you want to go with his father
it's his father that's correct
what does kakashi tell boruto that he
lacks
originality everything if only
originally
not honor not i think it's honor or
courage i would
you think so is it resolved i
bordeaux i don't know i've never seen
burj i assume borg is just like
i'm better than my dad [ __ ] with dad
like you've absolutely nailed that
character there that is exactly where
you like
so my guess is either like integrity or
honor
like i think resolve broad really has
like enough
you know i'm gonna say integrity
integrity
sure why not it was resolved he's
his problem is that he thinks he's the
best already and he doesn't know
you got 12 out of 15 correct
okay that makes you a ninja not bad
song one you are ready to defend the
hidden leaf village
with a score like this are you ready to
become hokage probably not
but then again who is um that's true
that's true that's fair that's fair
okay so we've done uh
that one uh
we've done the best have you seen
haikyuu
i have uh actually this is uh
wait let's see let's see i haven't i
haven't seen this one piece
quiz someone was searching for one piece
swimsuit which uh
you gotta respect that the hardest
one-piece quiz you'll ever
take someone are you ready let's do it
let's do it
yeah yeah which of the following arcs
are and can you see this i'll make it
bigger
okay i can see it a little more a little
more there you go is that good
yeah okay let's get rid of this ad get
out of here
to infinite the only way you would know
this is if you've read both the really
[ __ ] long manga
and watched which of the following arcs
are anime only filler the long ring
long land arc the foxy's return arc
the g8 marine base arc both a and b
both b and c holy [ __ ] i don't know this
i know i know this you got this it's b
and c both b and c
so the foxy return arc and the g8 marine
base arc
that's correct the long ring long land
arc is cannon
occurring between the sky pier and water
seven arcs in the manga
the foxy is returning it only happened
in anime okay what was the name of
jinbe's former captain while he was
member of the sun pirates
easy fisher tiger fisher tiger
is this the is this the anime you're
most confident about knowing everything
in
no but i know if the questions are like
this i'm not
you got this i will see you okay jinbe's
captain while he was
a member let's see if you can get a
perfect score of the sound price was
fish tiger okay cool oh this
next one is tricky how many different
full-length swords
you know what you signed up for when we
clicked the link
well how many different swords while
someone
thinks about it i'm just going to remind
everyone that they can go to tinyurl.com
for slash play for all 2021 to donate
money towards
ablegamers a charity that is doing
extraordinary work in combating social
iso
so short isolation you've probably been
at home for the past year and a half and
you probably have felt those feelings of
being isolated or even lonely
imagine that imagine if that was how you
felt always
and your only avenue to you know address
that was play some games
and then imagine that playing games was
not as easy as picking up a controller
you have various
disabilities or other considerations
that make that impossible that's what
ablegamers tries
to work towards breaking down the
barriers around
and any amount that you can donate is
super helpful for that
um and i always say when you invest in
accessibility for disabled gamers you
are investing in the future
of video games itself so please do that
if you can
someone how many different forms
yes i don't know i'm gonna say ten i
think it's ten
ten how many he's got in his picture one
two three
four five six seven eight in this
picture eight is an option here though
so let's go ten you nailed it
chapter one thousand zoro has wielded
ten different full-length swords
canonically five of them were named
blades with those being
sunday
the other five were made up of his two
unnamed katanas from the east blue ark
johnny and yosaku's blades during the
arlong park arc
and navy officers cutlass during the
water seven arc i need to get back into
one piece this sounds amazing
i mean i've seen all of that stuff which
is not an attack that luffy has used at
some point in the
manga gum gomugamu pistol gamagamu
missile
rifle okay
specifically the manga so he might have
used it in the anime
could be
it's either missile or slingshot
i think uh
[Music]
haven't read the manga can't help you
with this
it's not pistol it's not rifle it's not
shotgun missile or slingshot
we're going to stick i'm going to say
missile i don't think i've heard of
missile i'm okay i think he has done
myself but we're going to lock him
missile
i think he does missile again when he
uses gears
gear second for the first time oh maybe
yes shock slingshot he uses missile and
rifle
one after the other in the uh
scene gotcha i only know that because i
literally watched it the other day like
i said
uh gomogomo's slingshot has only ever
appeared in the anime was used by luffy
to intercept projectiles
fired at him during the anime filler arc
warship island
how many times was whitebeard shot with
bullets during the paramount
war arc hmm
let's see the numbers can't scroll down
uh we've got 152
72 267 2
and 46 times god damn how is this man
still alive
oh i don't remember i'm going to
say
interesting they put the word times
after just 46 not the others
right i was wondering i'm like does is
that a clue that this is the right
answer
my guess is
252 i'm going to say 152 152 he's got
two big bullet holes in him here
152 wow following whitebeard
it is revealed how many times he was
injured during the conflict the passage
reads the total number of swords wounds
he received in this bout was 267 he was
stabbed 267 times and then shot 152
times and hit by 46 cannonballs
how is what how is he alive
what in the world which is the correct
ordering of the straw hats
bounties from highest to lowest as of
the bueno arc
oh here we go oh one of the options is
none of the above
[Laughter]
um luffy's gotta be number one right
luffy's gotta be number one so that
helps you eliminate a bunch of them
luffy plus the two answers there are not
correct and then it's the above it's not
it's not the second one so it's either
the first one or none of the above
you know i don't keep track of the
bounties that much luffy zorro sanji
does sound right
i don't know if it's robin usop though
after that like especially if we're
cutting jimbei
yeah if jimbei's here i think it's none
of the above
oh no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait luffy jimbo
stop robbing nami we stopped himself has
a mega power-up doesn't he
so god yeah way up okay also
just want to point out that uh sanji's
poster is still the greatest of all time
yes i truly love to see that uh
from high slowest okay okay yeah we
don't know so it is luffy jimbei sanji
zorro who stop robin frankie brooke
nami chopper brook is the best member of
these rawhide pirates
that is absolutely not true but let's
continue okay who is who is it then
who's uh zoro nami
uh those are those are my favorites but
brooke
jimbei as well i love jinbe brook on the
ghost ship sipping tea
come on of the one piece with the ones
which did not have a double fruit power
uh guest spark pod okay
yeah wow these are some names
yeah it's wrong oh [ __ ] it was baron oh
[ __ ] uh gas card that was the only movie
i haven't seen of these
i forgot that i forgot that baron
omatsuri
doesn't have a devil fruit power baron
power
and i was like yeah it's a devil fruit
power totally forgot he relies on
modified arrows and the supernatural
powers of lily a parasitic plant that he
has formed a symbiotic relationship with
how many times has red head shanks
appeared in the manga as of chapter 1000
who the [ __ ] knows this [ __ ] okay let's
see what are the choices
you know oh my god there's they're
saying
they're all really close together yeah
i'm gonna say 19 19 times
19 18
one yes window too many uh
large chunk of him have shown him via
important flashbacks
pertaining to goldie roger and his crew
which tv special shows luffy learn the
red hawk technique
that would be probably oh my god number
[ __ ] me
uh it's either three i think it's either
3d 2y
or none of the above i'm going to guess
3d2y
3d2 it sounds like a kingdom hearts game
and i hate it yeah
um that was correct 3d2y climax sees
luffy's red hawk technique for the first
time against the film
film what is red hawk technique song one
it is a technique inspired by ace it's
like a fiery like ah
ken no ace technique okay how did jaguar
d
sold the giant robin met as a child
laugh
was
okay which one is your favorite laugh
though because mine say
that's that's black beard that's black
beard yeah i i frequent
i forget who that is it's the last one
ah that's goof
this one is yeah is one i frequently do
around the house and it annoys everyone
nice uh jaguar diesel uh the shipwrecked
giant robin here
robin forces herself to laugh in the
same way when she needs to lift up her
spirits
that's always good what seed does sanji
already come from east blue west blue
north blue south blue or the grand line
i think we like we just like my friends
and i just had a conversation about this
i'm not sure i think it's north blue
north blue i thought it was east blues
but my memory is bad
it's in north yes north dakota grew up
in east blue
yeah yeah bauer ta is in the east blue
but he was born in
north blue ah to the vinsmoke family
he lived with them until he decided to
disown them for the cruelty
running away to come and encounter his
death okay how many years passed between
brooks crew being wiped out and he's
joining the straw hat pirates
look at this absolute legend
he is i believe it's 50. 50.
nailed it his first crew they're run by
pirates brook was stuck in a florida
triangle for 50 years
how did nolan delaia and chandler and
warrior color
kalgara become friends in the skypier
flashback those are
what i don't remember any of this oh
okay um nolan helped cure the residents
of calgary's village suffering from a
plague
nolan chopped down the trees poisoning
calgary's village
calgary saved nolan from his execution
cargo saved nolan from the giant snake
looking to eat him
the two rang the golden bell of shandora
together how are they
how did they be go up sorry so how did
they become
friends in the skypia flashback
oh this is gibberish to me i have no
idea
the bell is like a big part of that arc
right like it's like
like um it's not it's not the middle one
unfortunately it's not he did not save
it from his execution
uh it's either i'm get i'm gonna guess
it's as simple as golden bell but i
could be wrong yeah that might be
they're already friends
incorrect nolan helped cure the
residents of calgary's village
suffering from the plague okay
okay following the time skip which straw
hat was the first to reach
the thousand sunny oh
oh the first the first one is it
i thought yeah doesn't frankie make it
well but it's when they're reunited
right go back up
okay i guess uh following the times yeah
yeah which was the first to reach it
uh you've got frankie robin who stops
zoro or nami
surely not zoro cause he always gets
lost
i think it's frankie while you're
thinking about it well thank you to
alexander yan for the 20
donation thank you so much alexander
appreciate it so we're going with
frankie we'll go with frankie
that was correct yeah yeah frankie's the
first arrive at the sunny after two year
time skip he also encounters bartholomew
kumar there
who guarded the sunny during the straw
hat's absence kumar great character
as of the one or arc which of these
characters has not been confirmed to be
dead spoilers for one piece coming up
portuguese the ace goldie roger absalom
ineru
hasn't been since seen since the skypier
arc in the anime the manga has shown
that henry is alive on the moon
via the start of chapter shorts which of
these characters was or is
a member of the marines belmer sengoku
x drake don't kyote all of them is all
of them right
yeah yeah belmair is a character i was
not very fond of
wow she's great i just i just don't like
her name honestly
um during the riveriak which character
was not shown in the mysterious king's
photos
luffy shirahoshi
correct only photos of the monarchs or
those with the ability to hear the
voices of the world are seen during this
brief chapter
with the as of yet unnamed monarch of
the world
how many warlords former or current has
luffy defeated in the
juana arc we've got five nine
seven four and 10.
oh
can you scroll up to that picture like
that'll kind of help a little bit yeah
you froze for a second then i was like
what's going on is he just like deep in
concentration or is he back
and then you pop i just go through the
if i just go through the arcs
he's beaten buggy he's beaten
he's beaten um crocodile
uh he's beaten moria
he's beaten flaming doflamingo
am i missing anybody um does a
l count and nell's not a warlord no
he's never beaten mihawk he's never
fought law i don't
ever be in law he never beat kuma i
don't think
blackbeard no hancock no jinbe no
i'm gonna say four four i'm wrong yeah
uh
my favorite one piece character there is
buggy
he's i think he's great yeah i've got
i've got the uh
model of him best one-piece character is
buggy but without the torso just the
feet in the head
that is the figure that i want yeah yeah
so you're right
crocodile maurya doflamingo and the
clown's the only waters that luffy has
four and one
which arc contained the first instance
of
haki he's blue skype here yeah skype
here
pretty sure wrong oh he's blue
oh wait because oh no this shanks
oh yeah we scrolled too
shanks scares off the the with the
monster i totally
yeah so yeah so east blue when when
luffy and i actually
played shanks in the first chapter yeah
that's technically hockey
yeah well not explicitly stated
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that does seem like the
[ __ ] yeah they kind of
skype does uh formally introduced
hockey yeah yeah they're kind of
retroactively
counting that then okay sure sure
it's like it's like rayatsu in in uh uh
bleach where they're like oh yeah that
was rare too like
across all of one piece manga movies and
anime which of luffy's friends have said
he'll be the king of pirates zoro
nami usap ace all of the above all the
above
all of them asus said it yeah
okay yes you got 14 now
20. not bad you're a grand line rookie
that means you've kept up with one piece
for a while now and while not everything
is about about it has stuck you've
retained enough to be a general
fount of knowledge keep reading and
watching and you very well might
end up being one of the most
knowledgeable fans out there
keeper is on one maybe one day you can
be as cool as all day
one day okay name another anime that you
want a quiz for and we'll search for it
how about about is there one for formal
alchemist not the
2003 one but the uh brotherhood the
brotherhood
can you 100 the full male alchemist
brotherhood quiz
let's try it before diving into this
quiz i want to give a shout out to
matt hawking he did 10 earlier this
stream and he just donated
another ten dollars fantastic thank you
matt
all right ready yeah spoilers for full
metal alchemist full metal alchemist
full metal alchemist full metal alcohol
um what color are scars eyes
red right red yes
yeah because they're brown skin red eyes
okay they don't tell you until the end
here
which of these animals wasn't part of a
kimura hybrid
cow dog life yeah dolphin seems a bit
like it
i would love what was van hoenheim's
slave number
i don't remember this what this this i
don't remember
uh my guess
i don't even remember this three three
twenty three
twenty three twenty twenty three okay
yeah what is
zolf j kimberly's first name
well you just said it's solved well
let's say did you just say this oh did i
oh it doesn't say that
oh my god my brain just filled it out
it's solved dolph or self
gunter kimberly
kim okay stupid brain
what is the name of the alchemy used in
sing
is it is it alcoholics
alchemy is it alka history
what is the first name of winry's
grandmother
hinako
uh which character spoilers for former
alchemist
kill the winry's parents was there
lieutenant armstrong
yeah who directed format alchemist
brotherhood
oh interesting uh directed
directed huh i'm gonna guess
oh i don't know it's i think no actually
they know the answer to this
uh i'm gonna guess hirochi onogi
is a very familiar name right yeah yeah
i don't even remember
where does van going home come from
a mistress i think it's
xerxes right let's go that's like the
original
yeah which homunculus is killed by
colonel mustang yeah
that's the that's the figure i have of
him where he's holding his
his abdomen that's one of the best
scenes in the anime
yeah it's brutal it's so hard to watch
again because she's like screaming
oh it's so good yeah what was father
code when he was first created
a dwarf in the flowers in a flask okay
either on it which of these artists did
not contribute to us
a song to the show's credits nico
touches the words
dts
[Laughter]
i would love to see a btsn song for
former alchemists though what does
colonel mustang have to sacrifice when
he opens the portal of truth
his hands his eyes his eyes his eyes
ah you hate to see it how does envy die
yeah oh uh oh hold on don't
oh what was it again it's it's
uh it's not killed by mustang mustang
just
fights him no no yeah it's not it's not
that i think he
wait i don't think he can it's
it's been so long because it's one of
those
things that they start breaking him down
right and he starts getting reduced to
his most
yeah basic form so you know
i remember i remember howie he just sort
of like dissolves
so it might be defeated by ed i think
like i think
[Music]
yeah decomposes something like that
i think it's defeated which character
did pride
consume kimberly marco ling or alphonse
uh kimberly there he is
how many episodes of the show are there
is it a nice 69 a 48 a 64 or a 55
oh oh
64 in that one okay for my alchemist 64.
the nintendo game we
never got it would have been amazing i
would have
what is the name of the fake priest in
lyor
is it cornelius cornell cornello
yeah cornell would be amazing
what is the name of shawtaka's daughter
slash dog
nina nina i hate you tonight
[Laughter]
uh what is the name of uh elect
brother's alchemy teacher
akuma right yeah
akuma taught uh the york brothers yeah
yeah
um what is the name of the military
installation between a mistress and
drachma
or briggs fort boyard is a
a british game show
oh yeah yeah fort briggs
where you can find armstrong's sister
what is the name of general armstrong's
assistant
that is the assistant is miles
miles yeah okay let's go miles
where did riza hawkeye have her father's
flame alchemy research
tattooed thigh right back shoulder yeah
what is the name of this shop where
mustangs forces get their ammo
oh havoc
general store we're going with that okay
who helps maria ross fake her death
colonel mustang general armstrong
alphonse and or winry
colonel mustang the best boy
what lab do eric and the eric brothers
find the slicer brothers and barry zach
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] damn oh [ __ ] sex
i think it's the third lab third lap
do you want to do a friend don't do
friends quiz after this
you're going for third probably not i'll
say third yeah
not even gunther could let's go 100 on
this central park of course
kimberly which kind of kills kimberly
oh i don't remember this uh hankel
zampano
joseo or darius i'm going to guess
heinkel pretty sure it's the lion the
one who like bites it or something
yeah what does edward sacrifice to get
alphonse body back this is a
comprehensive spoiler by the way
his ability to do alchemy yeah i hate to
see it
so we're getting to like the last few
episodes of the shows
how many children do eduard and winry
have
at the end of the show
is it two i think it's two i'm pretty
sure it's two
yeah yeah three seems too many well this
isn't fully
spoiling every final moment of this
where does
alphonse travel to at the end of the
show shing dragma rashford
okay which homunculus is the fastest one
of them all
gluttony slaughtered and violent fastest
fastest
i guess because he's like secretly the
fastest
he has to be like slowed down it's
either that or wrath
but uh probably or maybe it is wrath
i think it might be because yeah i
remember him being like he's
surprisingly fast he's fast as [ __ ] boy
[Music]
he scored ae7 so
yeah we got scars eyes were blue
our blue is that right what
what what that's wrong no way wait wait
wait wait
wait wait full me alchemist
scar
he does not he does not have blue eyes
he does not because the whole point is
like yeah he's got red he's issue
yeah he's like he's like oh i hate the
blonde hair blue eyes
what the guys are red as hell what is
what's up
full of [ __ ] everyone i'm sorry everyone
take a screenshot of this
and tweet at what culture and say your
full metal alchemist quiz is wrong
scars eyes are red not blue
you have upset you have upset pro zd
on the internet and now you've made some
powerful enemies
i mean we can't trust any of this now
but like
let's see let's see the ones that we did
i can't believe they did that
okay who directed you that's i guess
that's why it's familiar because okay
yeah
got it let's just make sure i like how
you're double checking everything
wikipedia
full metal format alchemist and formula
okay we're just gonna make we're gonna
make sure on this stuff
of the youtube chat right now this
website has lost all credibility
how does envy commit suicide no
that sounds great yeah this website what
culture is not trustworthy anymore
okay okay
all right let's just make sure fma
february
i'm pretty sure that's right yeah
laboratory five there he is
barry the chopper
okay what else have we got that's it
okay pretty big pretty good that's the
way you got one more
one more correct yeah it would have been
like i don't know 92. yeah
90 something like that so that's good
hey
how many did i get wrong on that uh
actually wrong so you only got
one two
two three three three wrong
okay that's solid
um okay pick another anime that you
wanna quiz for
while you're thinking about that we have
a few more donations in uh
one from ax avd
for fifteen dollars and he left a note
that tamora is his
favorite anime character hell yeah emoji
and another donation from an anonymous
source of twenty dollars
thank you so much i
let's see like what would be one does a
chat have any requests for like one like
uh
what kind of quiz we could do have you
seen
uh hajimeno ippo
i have but not in a long time okay well
let's not do that one then what's a good
one
how about what's the most recent anime
you watched that you feel comfortable
haikyuu
yeah i could one day spoilers because
i'm not oh
that's a good point that's a good point
i i've only seen and i haven't seen the
new season of the anime
so um i was i was gonna
bleach could be funny i didn't finish it
uh i was gonna type in
this is the ultimate bleach fan for quit
quiz for real fans
so if you didn't finish it it's going to
be tricky but i'm wanting to give it a
go
this one's this one's got gifts in it
oh it's got gifts huh uh
is there like a more jet is there like a
general one again
hardest anime quiz
ever
demonstrator image hottest anime already
intro okay let's go
ready sure yeah what is the meaning of
yuri
you asked for this song one you asked
for the meaning of yuri that's actually
kind of interesting
is it i guess petals petals yeah it all
sounds right
just because it's a match with what the
genre
of yuri is so submit my answer
incorrectly
that was one of those two i hate to see
it now what is the oh my god what is the
meaning of shika
okay is this just [ __ ] learning
japanese if this is
know this [ __ ] okay
is the golden lion and incorrect it's
there
if this is another what is the death
meaning of
no no no this is not the hardest
i will i will i will count those two as
wrong yeah
okay did we already do this one we got
another donation
uh from anonymous of one dollar with a
note saying oh my god
damn sabotage the last quiz by clicking
blue instead of red did i
no i'm pretty sure no i know i clicked i
could have saw when i clicked red
yeah i'm pretty sure we were good yeah
this is the hardest we knew with the
answer
this is the hardest anime quiz because
the only thing that this is going to
show you
is uh
this has to be that has to be a place
further than the unit you ready
right you want to do this one right yeah
let's do it okay
okay so station this
which one do you write i think it looks
like the art style of a placement i
think it's a place further than the
universe yeah you are correct yeah
a bus near shakuji station
[Music]
you know this seems too obvious so
uh it's not quintuplets
this is i don't think darling in the
bronx ever has a scene where they
go on a bus you know i'll go we'll go
with grid man we'll go with grid man
that was correct
wow tofu station is it gamers d frags i
don't know how to raise a boring
girlfriend or new game
no idea i'm gonna say new game oh new
game it is new game
that's uh the main character's phone
case wow
uh how do i know this why do i know the
answer goku jesus station
is that your lie in april sound in
phonium
musicals or sound of the sky that i
i have you seen your lion april i have
i'm gonna get sound euphonium okay i
think it's sound yeah
your line april is a perfect anime yeah
that hand is too detailed
it's gotta be it's like it looks so
pretty it has to be so well drawn
what you know
station this is a paper ticket
paper ticket two two of the shows are
isakai so it could have been that it
only showed up in like the very
the devil is a part-timer yeah
i don't know let's do it that's correct
akihabara station we've got stein's
gates
yeah yeah it looks like tone right
that's correct outfit this is very
impressive honestly
uh higashi future station
[Laughter]
oh that looks a lot like
the posmo pasmo is that
one of those i'll say you're lying in
april this time you're lying
okay incorrect it's much cooler oh my
gosh
it wasn't ozaki kun i knew that much
okay shinjuku station this is a really
well drawn one i'm gonna say garden of
words but
i could be wrong oh but it could be it
could be five centimeters
yeah oh it could be but you know what
five centimeters
five centimeters final answer yeah final
answer
correct yeah yeah this garden of words
is almost like photo realistic
yeah uh nishi kamakura station
i'm going to guess this is not dragon
maid
it's not dragon maid
it might be i'm going to say maggie
brilliant park
yeah okay i think so yeah okay sure
incorrect myriad colors phantom world
we got kawagoshi station
any of these are no i'm gonna it's i
think
i think it's obviously yeah totally
incorrect no never listen to me
hint akihabara station this is a nice uh
wallet
as well uh i'm gonna say
blend s correct cat
no i don't know what that is
love life bang your dream wake up girls
or local doll
uh go up i'm gonna get yes wake up girls
it is
real i don't know i don't know no it's
bang
yeah i'm like i don't think so tokyo
station
paper ticket space dandy legend of
galactic heroes a place forever in the
universe
classroom crisis it doesn't look based
for the universe again
now it can't be spaced out you surely
know
i'm going to say classroom crisis find
lansa
yeah yeah even in his classroom
yoshiki okay correct
okay yeah shinjuku station again
shirobako
ero manga sensei comic girls monthly
ghosts
incorrect it was comical
oh look at that phone trainer asu
kaiyama station
idol master be project idol master
bank dream bang dream again again kyoto
station a lot of character in here you
could probably this is not the time
again it looks kind of futuristic
inaudible homes of kyoto and
the eccentric family too i'll i'm gonna
guess
homes of that seems a little on the nose
i'm gonna say the eccentric family too
even though there was a
follow-up to the original eccentric
family correct
yeah all right minami
album um shinjuku station
red data girl girls under girls under
panzer
gurley air force one right a lot of
girls in this one
girlfriend beta i'm gonna i'm gonna go
with girlfriend beta no idea what that
is but let's go with it
i kind of i i was going to google
girlfriend beta but that's not going to
go well is it
it's red ago
i said this quiz is ridiculous
that's the same phone case right i'm not
crazy
is it the same they leave a different
angle
new game new game they're going to do
that
[Laughter]
station uh let's go with a lull in the
sea
nope okay someone is just like firing
from the hip now
just going at it uh harajuku station
[Music]
sweetness and sweetness and lightening i
think
alice and zoroku damn how many of these
are there oh my god we're almost there
we gotta watch our station
angel flew down to me incorrect there
was no idea what that is
no i don't know half of these titles uh
shakuji coin station march comes in like
a lion
what is this as miss beasley bob likes
it all right
watch it tam it's not good just skip it
i've always liked you and the answer
i've always liked you
i'm not sure myself where this was
through true tears if you
if you get this right ah it's nice cut
out the right oh they even told us
the correct answer kagura
station i'm gonna say
oh this domestic girlfriend yeah let's
go domestic girlfriend
it's a good hand good hand drawing there
nice perspective good hand drive
yeah it was the great passage what are
these anime
uh i have no idea i'm gonna go
oh uh i hope it's not monster monsoon
you know what monster musume let's do it
incorrect there's an interview with
monster ghost interview with monster
girls
which is a much better monster girl
anime
shimbashi station let's go
joker game i kind of want to see what
gurley air
they might be the correct answer gate
hon kawagoe station this i think is
tsukigakide
say it looks way too pretty to be teen
remember nice um
good arm chunky hand i like it
that was correct we finally we broke the
losing streak we're back boys
yeah all right we back kyoto station
welcome
march comes in like lying i have she
hired furu
i know you like that anime yeah that's
why i guess but
there's so many march comes do they go
in a station every [ __ ] episode
you got 12 32.
okay so 20 20 wrong got it okay easy
damn we do not know we were on a roll in
the beginning like we were not
kidding we're killing it for a bit
oh my god ultimate 30 toughest questions
for anime chris
oh this is just a week
okay let's go what else do we got
play quiz i hope this is what the what
in the world
absolutely not
hard anime quiz
okay we can do this one let's we can do
this one
whoa okay all right who was the first
crewmate luffy recreated in
in one piece oh it's going to be zorro
oh no zoro
let me click you oh do you just have to
like just
show answer and it will oh my god
oh no screw this screw this
what website is that that is quizzes.com
you are banned
you'll never be used again uh
quiz expo let's see
only 33 amazing anime quiz for anime
real fans
only 33 can pass anime quiz
let's go let's begin let's begin with an
easy question i like the way this is
like written
here who's the pokemon is the ash mystic
[Music]
is that your final answer uh well you
could argue that pikachu
is the main character yeah i wonder
probably ash
you could argue that misty is more
interesting but yeah yeah i mean they do
acknowledge that we're starting with an
easy one so let's see how we go a girl
searches for metal objects to fulfill
her wish which is the anime
i mean it's a girl yeah so this girl
disco
i think they're fooling us they're i
think they're talking about bulma so
dragon ball
okay wait is she if they're talking
about the oh magical i read that as
metal objects
because if it's a girl in general then
it's fairy tale yeah but
dragon ball oh wait that's also about oh
well okay
yeah correct why have they not shown a
picture of said girl
what's going on here ridiculous what
kind of wizard
is lucy in fairy tale anime no picture
he is a celestial wizard
someone i'm glad we have i'm obviously a
celestial wizard
okay i'm glad you're an expert in fairy
tale as well as all the others i love
fairy there she is is that her
is that lucy that is her yes this is the
uh senior video editor at gamespot lucy
here
who is he who is this guy oh ash again
again someone really didn't try someone
at quiz expo was
phoning it in one day uh goku
it's like the last three questions of
this though get like wait imagine
he is goku in dragon ball anime he is an
alone boy
we had one dragon ball goku's abilities
include kaio ken
super elbow smash slash down kick and
arrow knee i've never
heard of anyone
yeah okay which of the following
characters
does not does the gum gum pistol attack
belong to
oh chill bits clowns
uh i'll just i'll just answer for you
thank you
tough for me monkey d luffy is the main
character of one piece
anime a curious boy who wants to become
a king of pirates and the gum gum pistol
is his signature attack is that right
signature yeah the pistol i would say
it's a signature
okay fair enough naruto has different
types of modes do you know what this
is what is the name of this mode
oh this i don't know i'm gonna guess six
paths sage mode
i'll just be none of them that is
correct
this is six path stage mode and is the
favored move of
naruto's power ah
well done well done narotto
he is like yoga me he is the main
character of pokemon
anime fairy tale dragon balls
one piece fairy tale or death note
i mean pokemon i'm gonna go definitely
okay um okay
right let's go
he is the main character of death note
anime thank you very much
this picture is from which one of these
famous animes good luck with this
they aren't gonna show us huh okay
obviously
spirited away you know why they're
calling it via yahoo news
oh clearly my neighbor totoro okay
right away if you get it if you get this
someone this is gonna go down in twitch
history as one of the greatest moments
on twitch ready yeah
he's done it he's done it
easy easy he's done it
oh this picture is part of sprayed away
anime it was created by hayao
zaki's about a ten year year i never
want to know what the picture was
it was just that which one of these
characters
is the oren high school host club
anime's main character
oh my god i think it's i think it's all
uh naruto stage
it's noirato thank you naroto oh yeah
this is haruhi
thank you very much uh quiz expo dot com
do you know what kind of person naruto
is
oh he's a tree surgeon
what anime character is a tree surgeon
though
i would love to see a good question uh
i'm going to search for it
tree surgeon anime
the tree surgeon 1994 good luck enjoying
that last day
okay a ninja
naruto is a young ninja okay
we don't we don't have many questions
left and we're reaching the end of the
stream so
who is he who is he who is he
of course yep done
zoro is monkey life's best friend in one
piece anime is he his best friend
i think it's yeah probably do you know
this couple is from which one of these
animes
song
can you do it twice
it's definitely kirito and asuna they
definitely have a picture of them
oh my god
i i'm just good at anime i'm sorry what
can i say
this is uh we have to crown you the king
of weebs now
yeah this cat is one of the cute
characters of
which anime
we've reached the end of the stream time
so we're going oh he's wrong l is a boy
that is
he's from
i got that wrong so i guess i'll have to
uh yep mark that
last question last question do you the
name of this character
uh classic haruka obviously
um it's sophie sophia is it sophie
it is sophie yes
well done here's a blu-ray or paul's
moving castle as your gift uh
someone we've reached the end of our
stream thank you so much for hanging out
with us this is the most fun i've had in
a long time
absolutely thank you for having me uh
this was
this was an of honor of course you
guessed
two of the hardest anime quiz questions
without even seeing the images so you
officially
as far as gamespot is concerned the king
of anime
on the internet feel free to add that to
your resume add it to your
your marketing materials let people know
that you are officially the king of
anime
yeah i'm pretty sure from now on i'm
only going to
uh respond to people uh if they address
me as such
and if not then i will not respond of
course um
king of anime king of anime and how much
did you have to donate towards the end
there
uh what i'm gonna do is it's 53 but i'm
also going to tack on
some extra just for being the king of
anime oh hell yeah
i'm gonna benevolent king i'm gonna
match match your
uh 53. oh my lord oh my god
thank you so much that's incredible
someone you're a treasure wait
we we
you know what i'll i'll figure it out
i'll do it
don't i'll do it upper shut up tab
someone thank you so much
for we know you're extremely busy thank
you so much for hanging out with us and
doing the anime quiz
it's been an honor to hang out with you
um
where can people find you and what is
there anything that you want to plug
uh yeah i'm on youtube pro zd p-r-o-z-d
also on twitter pro-zv pro zd just
google pro cd uh you'll find me on all
social medias and uh i'm also a voice
actor so just
follow me on twitter you'll get my
updates on that otherwise
yeah thank you guys this has been fun
for sure you should definitely follow
uh someone on twitter is hilarious and
always a treat to see popping up in the
timeline
in the meantime we'll catch you again
tomorrow at 10 a.m pt
for another stream and then we'll have
another one at 2pm pt
uh we've got two more days of play for
all charity streaming and we want to try
and get to
30k but we probably won't make that
let's aim for 10k let's let's aim for
10k okay let's just go with that
pretty page that's all or nothing
anyways thank you so much everyone peace
out have a good day